hey everyone here on the freako camp
channel looking to get some tips on how
to make award-winning javascript games
my name is anu cooper and i'm a software
developer and course creator on youtube
as well as judge for the 2021 js 13
games competition for those of you who
have not come across the js 13 games
competition it is a javascript coding
competition for html5 game developers
running yearly since 2012.
each year a theme is given in 2021 it
was space and the fun lies in the fact
that the total file size limit of your
game submissions has to be under 13kb as
per the name
and just what can you make with that in
kb of javascript well just have a look
at some of these awesome games
in this video we will be looking at the
top 20 winners from the js 13k game
competition as well as hearing from the
game creators themselves he will talk
you through the game and provide you
with some of the game source code so
that you can have a look for yourself
what it takes to make each game
this video is great for those new to
javascript game development and those
wanting to get in on the next year's
competition
so i hope you enjoy it now let's get to
it
so the rules are simple all your code
and game assets should be smaller than
or equal to 13 kilobytes or to be exact
13
312 bytes when zipped your zip package
should contain an index.html file in the
top level folder structure and when
unzipped should work in the browser
next you can't use any libraries images
or data files hosted on server or
services that provide any type of data
so for example google fonts are not
permitted analytics and other stack
collecting scripts are also not allowed
all the game assets should fit in the
package size limit however the a-frame
babylon js and 3gs frameworks are not
counted towards that limit but you can
use them only in the web xr category
and finally stick to the theme this is
very much recommended but also free to
interpretation there are some pretty
creative implementations of the theme of
space in this year's competition which i
can't wait to share with you
okay great now that we have the rules
covered let's hear from the competition
creator andrei mazur
hello there my name is andrey mazur and
i'm the creator of the js 18k games
competition
if you don't know it's a javascript
coding competition for html5 game
developers where you have a whole month
to create a game within the 13 kilobytes
zip limit
it runs yearly every august since 2012
so
recently we had our 10th edition already
we're receiving an incredible amount of
really awesome games submitted over the
years
many developers publish
making of blog posts
and every single
game have its source code published on
github so there's plenty of
opportunities
to learn from the best
and the top 20 winners from this edition
will be presented by developers
themselves in this very video so make
sure to check it out
okay so let's do it let's start from the
game winner number 20 and work our way
up to reveal the number one winner of
the js 13k games 2021 competition
in spot number 20 we have hit the space
by kimbat if you want to learn how to
make a game with movement as smooth as
butter hit the space is definitely worth
a look
in this game you hold spacebar to
accelerate your ship reaching
checkpoints to advance while avoiding
hitting planets and going near black
holes what is also great about this game
is that you can see the remaining fuel
in the top left corner at all times as
without any fuel you cannot accelerate
any further
the only thing that will apprentice your
fuel are the different checkpoints you
need to hit
if we have a look at the code we can see
how well structured the game is
everything from the graphics to the
audio has been organized in such a way
that is readable to anyone wanting to
have a look
now for those of you who have not had a
go at playing around with webgl
webgl enables web content to use an api
based on opengl es 2.0 to perform 2d and
3d rendering in an html canvas in
browsers that support it without the use
of plugins webgl programs consist of
control code written in javascript and
shader code or glsl that is executed on
a computer's graphic processing unit
you can see it being instantiated here
and its methods being used throughout
the project to be exact this is webgl2
and if you want to learn more about it
and its fundamentals please
go here
if you use the javascript library 3js
this kind of code might look familiar to
you that is because libraries or
frameworks such as 3js and babylon js
encapsulate webgl's capabilities making
it easier to build 3d applications and
games
of this game judge bjorn ritzel said
catchy music i like this slingshot
gravity and it feels just about right in
terms of difficulty i wonder how the
game would play if it was possible to
zoom out and see the target planet
before launching
and i said that it was deceptively
harder than it looks
maybe i'm just bad at the game though if
you want to have a go yourself please
check out the link for the game
and its source code in the description
below
at number 19 we have galaxy raid by
joseph del rio
what was great about this game was the
fact that there were levels to be
unlocked pretty impressive for a game
that is only 13kb in size
in this game you fight your way through
six different missions collect fragments
and upgrade your ship
on desktop the ship itself will follow
your cursor and a bomb will be launched
on the click of a button
the game also has a touch option in
which you can choose to move the ship
with your finger and tap with a second
finger to launch a bomb
don't want to use either of those
perhaps you want to use the keyboard
option
use the arrows or
wasd on your keyboard to move and the
space bar or enter to launch a bomb
and even more impressively there is also
a gamepad option which supports both
analog sticks and directional pads
use a b x or y to launch a bomb with
this method
this game really covered a lot for 13kb
and also managed to make the web
monetization part of the competition by
allowing coil members to customize their
ship color claim a thousand fragments
and unlock all missions
i also enjoyed all the cut scenes if you
want to cheat we can have a quick look
at the game code to have a read of all
the texts for those scenes
clearly a lot of thought has gone into
this game and i can't help but be super
impressed
and what did the experts have to say
nathan lai call this a nostalgic send up
of games like gallagher this game offers
a healthy amount of challenges and
satisfying progression with the upgrade
system all it really needs is some music
to make the action a little punchier but
overall the game is great the web
monetization features are excellent
given the amount of challenge present in
this game
normally i don't like being able to
simply bypass gameplay but in this case
this allows less skilled players to
experience the entire game in some form
and eva mazur said everything is well
marked both subscribers and
non-subscribers can read right away what
a bonus is you can clearly see when
options are available and when they are
not it's nice that there are several
bonuses the subscriber can decide for
himself which to choose bravo the
perfect implementation of web
monetization
at spot number 18 we have the game
escape by the duo who go by the name of
piazzco
[Music]
yes
oh hi we didn't see you there
i was just having fun with my dog
this is miho
and this is stash
and uh we're actually just playing our
trying to play i'm trying to play our
game on xbox here
the game is called escape and
it's our submission to this year's jsk
13k
js13kgames.com
competition
all right let's talk about escape
uh what is escape now
escape is a
short story driven platformer
uh with puzzles
what kind of puzzles like environmental
puzzles like what does that mean like
you push stuff you pull stuff you jump
over stuff jump into
etc um so it's basically walking jumping
pushing and pulling um
the the world that escape is set in
uh happens in near future where it's
clear that
the mankind has destroyed earth and the
only way
to
[Music]
to live
is to escape
it's basically too
late
or anything else so
we know we screwed up and
we need to find a new home right but
it's the game is not about finding the
new home it's not about destination
not about humans that escape it's about
whatever
we as mankind leave behind it's about
the nature it's about wildlife
um and in fact you play as
a wild animal right yeah you play as a
fox
that uh
tries to make it to the
ark
can we call it an arc yeah i think it's
an arc like a
last rocket that's supposed to leave
earth
and you're not the only one escaping
because like all the animals are
escaping everyone wants to survive so we
we try to create this sense of urgency
and danger
uh actually to be honest like since this
is all finished now i think we can be
frank uh like i'm not entirely sure we
succeeded
at conveying this sense of urgency like
you can see other animals escape uh in
the background but i feel like uh well
we also wanted to make this pretty
relaxed game
chill gameplay so like there is no rush
really
it's like witcher 3. well there is no
mechanic of rush the logic of rush in
in the game but the
environments uh kind of you know this is
kind of forcing you to do to to proceed
faster and faster because there's
uh
fire everywhere around you right right
so there are hints there are hinderers
like the world is burning
you better hurry up
exactly yeah
and you have your
cubs
cubs yeah that's just escaped uh in
random directions at the very beginning
of the game
before you even gain
control over the main player so
right so so you start out and like the
world is burning you better find the the
last rocket leaving earth soon and on
top of this
your
your baby your fox babies escaped and
you have to rescue them maybe we can
focus more on the technicalities now
yeah yeah of course so uh yeah let's
jump into it um
i think one one one thing that i would
really like to talk about is um is good
luck is the the framework that we use to
build this game um
in fact
good luck is
um
a project by mihaly myself that we
started two years ago
and it's the idea is that
we wanted to create this
template or or
like a set of good defaults
that we can use for our
games um mostly for our competition
games but not only
um
and
what what i think stands out is that
this is not your typical library
um you're not supposed to install it and
then import from it
in a way like every game is its own
engine and
at the end like and then
but at the same time no no game has it
has the engine
right instead of including uh good luck
like you would include your typical game
engine into your project you just clone
the repository or like use the template
ability of github
and
you use our
bootstrapping utility to create uh
a new project out of one of the examples
and you get a lot of codes already for
free there so um
you know if you're interested in 3d
physics
or
rendering of course but also some
utility systems like
moving around or
touch input like it's all there and it's
all ready to be used um well maybe we
should talk a little bit more what you
get uh as part of good luck and to to
talk about it i think it's uh it's a
good idea to talk about ecs right
right so every
entity has has different behaviors
attributed to it right
but but what's interesting about the ecs
architecture is that
the data for behaviors lives
completely separate from the logic of
the behavior right and that's so there's
a difference between components and
systems
and what i like what i like about this
architecture is that it allows you to
compose different
behaviors together to build something
smarter right something unexpected yeah
uh maybe we can show an example of this
i think what's interesting is that um
like the for example in this in this
blueprint or in this object essentially
blueprint is just a
name that we chose for functions that
create objects
the
the movement functionality is given by
the move components
and in fact there are other
objects in the game
that also can move and the only thing we
needed to do is add this very same
component to them and then it just
worked right so here miho is showing
the blueprint for a bird which is just
uh like a decoration in the background
but it does move and it flies away into
into the distance and you can see that
it also has the move component uh
by virtue of which um it does the moving
um
then like
the the move component the only thing it
defines is uh is how to move and how
fast to move once some other logic
decides that the entity should move so
for example we have this other component
called
control control always
which is just a super simple if you
think about it a super simple version of
ai which all it does is
moves
or tells the move system that this
entity should move forward every frame
well forward move in the direction
defined by right it's forwarding this
example
right um and you can see like we used
lifespan here as well which means that
you know after 10 seconds the bird you
know
has probably flown into the distance
into the fog so you can't see it anymore
uh and so we just destroy the object and
it's no more
so you can think of this like you you
compose
the behavior for an entity out of many
different components
and then you have
a number of systems that all work on
different combinations of these
components
uh so this one is actually very simple
it only works on the lifespan component
but maybe if you show a different one
yeah
maybe yeah this one yeah so shake
expects the entity to have a transform
and the shake components right so
actually every entity in the entire game
as long as it has these two components
will
go through the system and this is very
powerful like you can you can move
different things randomly that's what
this shake system does um depending on
where you need it and how you need it so
for example
when we implemented the
fire fire that's a particle emitter that
just moves
uh very quickly every frame randomly
and and produces this erratic effect it
looks like the fire is burning
in a wide volume of space
all this is just implemented using a
simple for loop and it's i think
i loved it and i still love that good
luck is so simple like that's the entire
logic of the game really is that you
have a couple of functions like a number
of functions
uh that and all they do is just
pretty
stupidly iterate over everything in the
world and see do i need to check this no
do i need to check this do i need to
check this and you can do this
thousands of times per frame and
it's crazy how performant
modern browsers and modern computers are
like uh i think when we profile this
like the entire uh update part of of the
game takes two or three milliseconds
it's it's it's nuts
um
right so
this is how where we where every systems
system is being called and every single
one of those iterate over
every entity inside the game and i think
last like content we
we had like 4 000 entities in the game
so like this is doing probably 20 or 25
iterations over all 10
4 000 of
uh entities and again it's it takes
almost no time at all um
which maybe is a little bit
counter-intuitive you know like
i i just
loved it when we first discovered that
the good old fort loop is actually the
most performant way of doing that let's
jump into um to how we build the world
of escape right so
we used blender to build our props
and the barn from the farm level
uh
we every every uh prop is built from
two
primitives i believe so we use a cube
most of
uh parts of this barn is cube
and we used a
cylinder
cylinder
yeah so as you can see here
those are just a bunch of cubes with a
cylinder inside
there so actually uh like a single barn
is what is it like uh 15 different
entities
each one rendering
a cube or a cylinder and they're all
put together
you know in the right place on the right
angle
um to give the the final original result
of
the bar and
right and we did the same for maps um
so every
element
here in the map
is uh has a name of uh prop
like we have a boost property we have a
box property bar that i showed you
earlier
and
uh they're just cubes here on in this
file right but they're they're just
cuter cylinders here because of the
well i don't know why this was easier
and when when we export the file like
that
uh oh
okay it's the the the logic here is the
same with as it was in exporting props
like every
uh no this is ground but
so for instance we have a fence instance
that's located in some place of uh
of the word and it's rotated uh and
scaled according to
how it is in the how we set it up in
blender
right all right
yeah i think that's that's all i wanted
to say about escape
but be sure to you know play it
if you thought this was interesting and
whenever you feel like
learning about game dev or
making your own game
give good luck a try yeah consider it as
your next js13k
tool yeah two of choice
all right thanks thanks
at spot 17 we have the game gamut shift
by one grumpy dude
the first thing that is hard to miss
about this game is the cool transitions
and wonderful 3d graphics once again
thanks to webgl2
this game asks you to push stuff around
to essentially unlock passageways and
reach exit portals we use the w a s d
keys or arrow keys to move around and
the space bar to undo last push actions
as well as r to restart the current
level
levels are made by creating arrays of
symbols or texts that symbolize a game
piece similar to the approach on newer
game libraries such as kaboom js
you can view some of the levels in this
level.js file i like this approach as it
makes it easy for us as game developers
to visualize what we are working with
judge christo kaitila said phenomenal
when i saw loud audio head warning i
knew already this game was going to be
polished and thoughtful thank you for
that
then once the amazing music faded in and
the spectacular transition shaders
showed me the world full of awesome
detailed graphics my jaw hit the floor
wicked work
the shines the shadows the reflections
the warp lens effects on completing a
level beautiful the gameplay well it's a
nice soccer band game very familiar but
the puzzles were great and difficulty
progression was comfy and welcome
amazing work
at spot 16 we have adventure in asc 2
space by nicholas loss
[Music]
hello
my name is niklas
and i have a confession to make i'm a
game dev addict
4 years 13k this year i submitted 3
entries
[Music]
and they all ended up in top 50.
in this video i want to talk about two
of these games
so the first game i want to talk about
is adventure in ascii space which was my
main entry this year as a kid i played
games like io armalite
on my commodore 64 where you travel to
space
with your ship and shooting down enemies
watching out for bullets and i wanted to
make that kind of game this year
so i was very happy when i saw that
space was actually the theme
so here's the intro text
most people skip this if you didn't skip
it you got some instructions and you
also get an achievement in os 13k
so here is my ship
traveling through ascii space shutting
down enemies
collecting resources
and with these resources
i have an upgrade panel
so i can
yeah it's upgrade tree so you need to
pick
to pick things in the right order or
select which one you want to have first
which tree to select
and this will increase the the laser
speed for example
[Music]
but then it became quite boring i mean
just this random formations
so i started to add in
levels
so just
one more upgrade here
as you can see here levels
then
you couldn't lose
and
then i added in checkpoints this was a
bit problematic
because i could have automatic
checkpoints but then you might lose some
of these materials
like i did here
the problem was that some people that
didn't read the instructions thought
that
that c
came towards me was actually an enemy
and avoided them
so yeah i'm not going to show the whole
the whole level but this is the start
the start of the
level
as you could see the game is ascii based
so i didn't draw any graphic at all
i had that issue last year
the texture got a bit too big took up
too much space and
had to remove gameplay from from the
game so i was thinking oh maybe i will
just do an ascii graphic
and ascii is built into web browsers
because that's just a font
so you can see here that i'm actually
just
creating an
canvas
where i'm filling with text
so this is the character this is
actually the ship
i have a few
characters
that i'm using later on as sprites
and
this is actually the heart
there's an ascii code for that so you
can get a heart for displaying the
health
also i'm using some tricks
for generating
well fake light
and for that i need a
circle
so i'm actually adding a circle here as
well
that i'm using later to create fake
light
one issue i had with this technique was
that this font is a little bit different
in different web browsers i mean that's
okay
they look a bit different but actually
positions differs a little bit as well
and
not even
in web browsers on the same operating
system
actually it was the differ on different
windows 10 versions
so i had to add a little bit of
padding around
each character
which ended up as a sprite in that but
you know and i think it worked i tested
on a bunch of different operating system
and browsers and i didn't see anyone
complain about it
everything is mgl
i'm using this tiny sprite
module
that i found on the es13k resource page
so i didn't have to do the webgl stuff
myself this time
so why do i need webgl
well as you can see there's a lot of
things going on
particles and bullets
and
doing that without webgl would have
caused the game to be very very very low
fps
one last thing i want to show before
moving on to next game is the level
so to generate the level i actually draw
it here in [ __ ]
and this is actually the level as a png
file
where you can see the
level structure
the different entities
and
and also decorations
everything has different colors
in the end the png file is
a bit too big actually
so i needed a way to compress it even
further
and
i
wrote a level compiler this is actually
something i did for my game last year so
i've been reusing my own code
so i'm going through
the image data
and looking at the rgb colors
and when they match
i'm adding
a character to a text file
and then i do that for
every color in
in the png file
and that will end up as a text file like
this
this is
much better this can be compressed a lot
and then in the game i'm reading this
text file
and
i'm picking the level character here
i'm adding tiles
or adding formations or whatever i want
so that's a very
silly way to make a level
and then
i was basically done with the game and i
had almost three weeks
left so i started to play around with
another game called running out of space
i didn't mean to submit it but in the
end it became quite okay game
but it's actually not the one i'm going
to talk about now it's this one space
block invaders
and i didn't mean to make a game of it
actually in the beginning i just wanted
to see how much of a minecraft clone
could be done in 13 kilobytes
so what you see here is basically
the first day
i was having blocks
added and created
and
i had noise functions to create a very
simple
landscape
i didn't have any collisions at all here
so i'm just flying around in a very
limited area
then i was working on the code a bit
more
i was ending collisions and i thought
that would be
very difficult
but in the end it turned out
fairly easy to do and i had the
collisions done in like 30 minutes or so
using aab
collisions so here we can see that i can
walk around i can actually place blocks
and remove blocks
and the following day i added trees
minecraft has a lot of trees
so i was adding entries as well
and as you can see there is some very
basic
shadows
under the trees
so that's a kind of emulated sunlight
then i worked almost two days on
implementing ambient occlusion
so as you can see here the shadows under
the trees is much much more smooth now
and a bunch of issues
getting this technique
right
and there's actually some
bikes still in it
but it's not very visible
this gives them very smooth smooth
shadows
this was just three days before the
deadline
and i actually got a whole day on my own
which i didn't plan
and
i couldn't resist i added some very
simple gameplay to this world so i
made
the space invader character
and you have to run around and shoot
them before this they destroy the world
it's actually not really fun gameplay
there's no
goal of the game
but this was what i had time to add in
one day
me
[Music]
so what did i do to make the game run
fast in a web browser well first of all
i'm using webgl this would have been
impossible to do
without
webgl actually reusing code again
from my
entry last year
where i had some
basic mesh generation
so this is
normal mgl stuff
i have a mesh builder
so i don't have to fiddle with
vertices in other classes so i can just
say
at the left side
and right side to the mesh
with the right ue
values colors
and other
light values
and
yeah i think that's all the properties
so the world is basically an empty shell
you only want to render what's visible
to the player
so if you have two blocks on top of each
other
we don't want to render the top of the
bottom block
we don't want to render the bottom of
the upper
block
if that makes sense because that would
never be visible
so
when i'm building the mesh
i'm actually checking here
if the
block at the top if that's
not
existing yeah then add
the top side
and then we do that for all all the
sides of the block
and that
makes a huge difference
if we had didn't have this code the
game would be very very very slow
and this is the texture atlas i'm using
so this is all the textures in the game
but because it's repeating
all over in a 3d world
it looks like much more
and i'm also tinting and using different
tricks to reuse the same
texture
in various ways
after the competition i continued to
work on this for about a week
adding in
basically endless terrain so it's
rendering
until the web browser runs out of memory
uh i under
basic crafting
and a ui for that and different type of
tools
i also added a sheep that walks around
very stupid ai
but
yeah gives a bit
life to the world
i added water but that's just an
illusion it looks like water but when
you
you can go through it but you can't
can swim
then i started adding in caves and
i didn't get
the result i wanted from the caves and
somewhere around that point i actually
start to stop working on this
but i might reuse the engine or parts of
the engine next year
for you guys 13k who knows
so that's all i have to show uh well i
could actually talk about this for hours
but i have to keep this
short
the music you ever heard in the
background is my own uh there's links
here
showing
my two albums on spotify
i have a blog
that's very inactive
i have twitter
just ping midair if you want to
talk about something
and see you next year in js 13k
at place 15 we have q1 k3 by photoslab
hi my name is dominic and this is my
js13k entry for 2021.
i'm not really sure how to pronounce it
so let's just call it quick
this game was done as a tribute to the
original quake from 1996 and uh it
doesn't really match the competition's
theme but i really really wanted to do
this so here we are
um quick features two levels five types
of enemies three different weapons 30
different textures
a robust collision detection
not so smart but not completely dumb ai
some nice ambient music and spatial
audio
i want to go into some more detail about
how all the data fits into the game how
the textures levels and models are
stored
let's start with the levels i had some
experience with building levels or maps
as we called them for quake 3. since i
was aiming to reproduce parts of quake 1
i thought using a map editor for quake
would be a good fit
back in the day we used a tool called
radiant and while it wasn't really bad
in hindsight it feels a bit clunky
so this is trench broom it's a map
editor for various quake engine games
made by christian dusker and i can't say
enough nice words about it it's really
really good it's completely free and
open source so go check it out
while quake maps allow for all kinds of
funky geometry i limited myself to only
use access align blocks these blocks can
be quite small to allow for stair steps
or some details in the maps but they can
also be huge one block can cover the
floor or the ceiling of multiple rooms
i was able to capture most of the famous
e1 m1 map from quake 1 the slip gate
complex with just about 200 of these
blocks
i have to admit though that the original
map comes with a lot of secret passages
and rooms that i wasn't able to fit in
so
these 200 blocks can be stored in a
binary file with just seven bytes each
one byte for the x y and z coordinates
of the block and one byte for the width
length and height
and another byte for the texture index
these binary files with all the blocks
are loaded in javascript into a big
array buffer and all the vertices for
webgl are constructed from it
the entities so all the things that are
in the map the light sources the enemies
ammo and health boxes and so on are
stored with one byte each for the type
id
three bytes for the position and two
extra bytes for some extra attributes
for instance for the light sources one
of these extra bytes is used for the
brightness and one is used for the color
value
so with all this in the end i managed to
squeeze in two maps uh using up a
whopping 3.2 kilobytes in the zip file
the models for the game again are stored
in the simplest way possible it's just a
set of three byte coordinates defining
the vertices and then a list of indices
where each three indices define one
triangle or face of the model
for the animated models the list of
vertices is just repeated for each
animation frame
i was able to get away with very few
animation frames by just linearly
interpolating between them
i was using wings 3d to create those
models i exported them as a wavefront
object file and converted them into a
binary file with a php script
it's not really a good workflow and i
really should learn a bit of blender
next up textures
this was probably the best idea i had
for this game instead of creating your
textures as png files and just saving
them in the zip
the textures are created on the fly as
canvas elements when you first load up
the game
this idea is nothing new the demo scene
has done it since forever but i falsely
assumed that you needed some complex
operations to achieve good results with
generated textures
nevertheless i tinkered a bit with the
idea and after some promising first
results with drawing random stuff on
canvas elements
i build a really simple editor to create
those textures and i mean really really
simple this editor just supports five
different operations
you can draw a rectangle you can draw a
grid of rectangles you can draw some
random noise draw text or draw a
previous texture
in the end i was quite surprised myself
with the results you can get with this
it was really unexpected
also it turned out to be a lot of fun to
build those textures
the result of all this is a json array
that defines those textures all 30 of
them
and a tiny library that reads this area
and spits out canvas elements
the whole thing is on github it's called
tiny texture tumbler if you want to
check it out
i won't go into detail of how the music
is stored but the short version is that
it's similar to the textures
it's just a json array of notes that
gets rendered into an audio buffer
so with all the data out of the way i
had about 5.9 kilobytes left for the
code
i want to show just two things in the
code in particular and one of those
things is the renderer
i'm using webgl to draw everything onto
the screen and everything in through in
the game world is spit out to the gpu
for each frame there's no occlusion
culling or fancy math to figure out the
visibility
and it doesn't really matter computers
are fast
the renderer uses only one shader
program for everything so all the
enemies and the whole game world are
drawn with the same shader the vertex
shader handles the view rotation the
direction you look at
the view position the object's position
the object's rotation and blending
between two animation frames for an
object of course it's inefficient to
draw the static world geometry of a
shader that can plant animation frames
and rotate geometry but again it doesn't
really matter computers are fast
the fragment shader applies a uniform
array of light coordinates and light
colors to every pixel and does little
else
it does this in a loop one iteration for
each light source
so the number of lights in the game is
fixed to 32
and to stay within this limit the lights
are faded out after a certain distance
you can see this fade out in a few parts
of the game but
honestly i think it looks cool and it
adds to the atmosphere it's a feature
not a bug
completely unrelated to rendering here's
the collision detection routine that is
executed for each entity for each frame
this is very similar to what i was doing
in my previous game under run but this
time i'm doing it in three dimensions
instead of two but the idea is the same
first you remember the current known
good position of an entity you advance
this position according to the entity's
velocity and you test if the final x
position of this entity with the old y
and old z position collides if yes you
roll back the final x position to the
old position
and then you do the same thing for the y
and z coordinates
checking each of the three axes
individually instead of just doing one
test with the final position
allows you to slide along the floor and
walls and it turned out to be really
robust
the real code that is used in the game
does a bit more stuff
in particular checks if we can step up a
staircase or if an entity needs to
bounce off from the ground this is used
for the bouncy credits for instance
but the gist is the same it's just a
bunch of simple checks no complex mass
stuff
there's one last thing i want to get
into and that's keyboard input if you do
wasd movement in your game i urge you to
use the keyboard events code property
this property is keyboard layout
agnostic which means wasd works on
french keyboards and z and y keys are
not switched on german keyboards the
code property basically reports the key
based on the us keyboard layout so
you're defining your keys by the
position on the keyboard no matter what
layout is actually used in the end so
the user's local keyboard layout is
completely ignored which is exactly what
you want for your games
that's about it if you're interested in
some more detail about the game i wrote
a making off post on my blog
foboslab.org
thanks for watching and see you next
year
at sport 14 we have the game celestial
lighthouse by tom hermans
hi i'm tom for geeing certain k last
year i made a game called excellent
found this year i made celestial
lighthouse which is a
physics puzzle game about placing blocks
in the atmosphere of planets
without letting them fall into the
planet's core
so to achieve this circular gravity i
adapted the physics library
matteo diaz
and their attract plugin
so today i'd like to demonstrate the
level formats
since adron file was a grid based game
the level format is quite
straightforward there
celestial lighthouse also required it
since generating all the physics shapes
manually would require a lot of codes
uh and so with case sdk you should
usually try to pack your data in as
little space as possible
preferably building in heart assumptions
that reduce file size
where possible
this is
why for example i chose to set this data
up as array instead
of objects with
more readable property games
so in celestial lighthouse each level
has a lava core and an atmosphere
so since this is a constant level to
find we just
define its uh size here
and the level generation code just takes
care of building the actual shapes based
on the inputs
furthermore we define which shapes can
appear as random to be placed by the
player
so simple shapes as defined here
can be a square rectangle or trapezium
this is then used by the game as a grab
bag of sorts
to randomly select the blocks place
once you place a certain number of
blocks
12 in this case you win the level
finally levels have
solid platforms those are these black
shapes in the level these can only be
regular polygons like
like triangles
squares
and even circles
uh you can also cut the shape in half
by making them negative
and if you require you can also change
the size
the starting angle
the scale
and you can even set
a rotation speed
and
yeah that's pretty much it i really
enjoyed this level forward because it
makes iterating on the level design
appraise
so my main takeaway here is to make it
easy as possible for yourself to test
and improve your game and the levels in
it
right
bye and thanks for watching
at number 13 we have space jam by mark
roquette hey folks i'm mark cassette i'm
a developer and musician currently based
in austin texas and today i'm going to
be talking a bit about my js13k entry
called space gym i actually got the idea
for space jam from playing farming games
like stardew valley i began to wonder if
it was possible to make a game where you
build up a settlement using musical
instruments as the building blocks for
the game in space jam the gameplay is
pretty simple
start off with
two
instruments and this oscillator
basically the way it works is you can
add new instruments to the board using
the notes that you collect when the
oscillator strikes an instrument
this way you can build up patterns and
beats and
ultimately earn more notes to unlock
more instruments
you can build additional oscillators to
kind of expand your beat repertoire
and place them in different areas of the
map
so next up i thought i would talk about
the spatial audio in space gym
basically the way this works at a high
level is you have this map
and you've got a grid
and the camera is kind of centered in
the middle of the map and there's
instruments
that you can place and they're going to
be some distance from
the camera
and that's kind of where your center is
as the player and so as these move you
know from left to right or up and down i
wanted to make sure that i was taking
into account their position relative
to this point
and controlling the audio effects
accordingly so the first thing that's
going to happen is they're going to pan
left or right so this is going to pan
slightly to the right this is going to
pin a little bit more to the left and if
an instrument is all the way at the
bounds of your viewport it's going to be
panning fully
in that direction so
panning is the first thing to come into
play
and then the second thing is just going
to be
based on the absolute distance from
the
center
that's going to affect the amount of
reverb that's applied to that sound
and also just the overall volume of that
sound
so
what that looks like in code
i've basically consolidated all of this
to this function and update spatial
effects is something that happens
up here in this move camera function so
yeah basically anytime the camera moves
uh relative to the instruments you need
to update their effects and so this has
got a bunch of other stuff going on but
again we're just going to hone in on
this function here so
this actually takes the instrument that
was affected
by this camera move
and then first it calculates the
pan values so
pan x is going to be the instrument's
position in the x direction
and the delta of that with the camera's
position in the x direction so again
just you know these types of values
right here that's in relation to the
viewport itself
uh and you clamp this here i just have
like a utility function that clamps
if you don't know about that look into
it it's super
useful for just any type of kind of
quantitative coding
but especially creative stuff like games
so basically what this is saying is the
pan x is never going to be less than
negative one or greater than one
same exact thing with the pan y just in
the y direction
the radius this is just a simple
calculation pythagorean theorem right
here
and again the radius is important
because
it controls the
volume
in at number 12 we have first contact by
mark vasilkov
hey hey people
marco silkov here i'm a security
enthusiast for misreal it's mv silko on
github and twitter and gmail what have
you and i'm working for this magnificent
little company called no name security
we do defensive cyber security for
protecting apis
the game i want to talk about today
first contact was written for the js 13
compo in 2021 it's a simple clicker game
and i have a footage of it here
so yeah
the usual staples of the genre are all
present it's instant gratification based
the game practically plays itself it's
not skill based what i attempted to do
with this formula was a little story
some of the things just happened and you
have no control over them there are two
different endings based on the subtle
player choice the sort of thing
now for the source code the thing i'm
sufficiently happy with is how it's
coded to the browser's javascript engine
the idea was to avoid problems like
performance problems during the high
level designs so that we don't need
super clever optimizations later like
two days before release i'll give two
small examples of that
first in javascript garbage collector
can unpredictably pause the execution of
your program and do its thing to free
memory and on a 60fps monitor you have
16 and a half milliseconds to render
each frame meaning that garbage
collector can drop frames easily and
make the game stutter and one workaround
for that is to just allocate everything
you need ahead of time so that garbage
collector has nothing to do
for example in the first contact game
there are all these objects there are
orbital platforms and cannons and
projectiles and of course the invaders
and every object is a very small state
machine with a small number of states
so let me show it here
in the source code a canon
can be either ready to fire or it can be
reloading
what helps with garbage collector is
that all objects have an additional
state which is called missing which you
can see right here
and so when we fire rocket we do not
allocate a new object like new rocket we
instead pre-allocate all of the rockets
at the start of the game set them to
missing by default and when we need it
to fire we find the first one that's
missing and use that when the rocket
hits it reverts back to the missing
state so we have zero locations and
garbage collector is very happy with us
so here you can see for example like the
canon which has all these states and
when we
add this start of the application when
we create all of the possible like like
cannons and rockets and invaders
we we just allocate them here there is
no allocation there is no like new canon
new rocket anywhere in the code apart
from this specific place at the
beginning of the game
yeah the second thing is also very small
and it's related to the fact that all
drawing in this game is done on html
canvas and canvas has great performance
but when you need to render possibly
thousands of objects in every frame at
60 frames per second or more
the rendering costs quickly end up the
trick is very simple let's say we have
these space invaders drawing one invader
is simple we make a bunch of line two
calls and then we call stroke feel or
what have you you all familiar with the
canvas api
now
what about drawing a thousand of these
it turns out one way to optimize mass
rendering is to first make all of the
line to calls for all the invaders
like here you can see the render method
for the invader
and it has all these line tools and
close path
and
when we
actually invoke this method here
we have a function to render all of the
inverters at once so it it first invokes
all the line tools and
only then it does
stroke or feel or anything
this works because the browser's canvas
implementation which is actually a high
performance signal code works best if we
give it a lot of stuff to rasterize at
once so like all of the invaders or all
of the particles at once
the anti-pattern here would be a calling
stroke like every time for each line
segment and this is known to kill
performance
so that's all from me come participate
in js 13k competition next year
in at number 11 we have shuttle deck by
ariel wexler
hi
my name is arielle and i'm the creator
of shuttle deck
you can find me on twitter as ari neon
shark i make all sorts of games
simulations and fun little procedural
animations
okay so let's dive right in and take a
look at shuttle deck
at its core shuttle deck is an infinite
runner crossed with a deck builder game
uh so i thought that would just be a
funny combination of genres i haven't
seen that done before
um so here i am professor zoren's lab
and we're serving kind of as a space
courier we'll be traveling between
planets avoiding obstacles on the way
and we need to help professor zorn over
here on the right to deliver his package
the xeno transponder so let's go ahead
and help him out
so here we are traveling through space
we see some minerals we see some
asteroids i have these cards down here i
can press on these cards and it will
actually change the lane that my
spaceship is in that was a pretty easy
run for me i didn't have any obstacles
that really were in my way
excellent in between
levels so i just i just move between two
planets there
every time i reach a new planet i'll
encounter some sort of strange character
in this case the street merchant and
he's offering me a few cards that i can
buy now in this case i don't actually
have enough minerals to buy the cards
that he's offering so uh we're gonna
have to go again let's check out one
more stop here and see if we'll actually
be able to afford something hmm i just
missed that that's unfortunate
and here we go
okay it's looking pretty good 16 usually
goes a long way all right the kepler
missile no problem let's go ahead and
grab one of those what this will help me
do
is if i have an asteroid in my way i'll
just be able to shoot it
boom and get it out of my way perfect so
that's the core of the game
um
and now i guess we can dive into a bit
of uh
how it all works
and what i'm really excited to share
with you guys is the event emitter i
have my own custom implementation of a
very very small
event emitter that i used in the game so
we'll look at the code in a moment but
let's just talk quickly about why this
is important in a game at all
so you just saw shuttle deck
and the way it actually works is this
the game engine itself is completely
decoupled from all of these other little
components they don't really know about
each other so so let's think for a
moment about you know maybe
how the main character shoots rockets
so the way that works is if you have the
you know shoot a rocket card right here
right
so we have that here
uh
the
player is going to click this and what's
going to happen is a little event is
going to be emitted and i'll just kind
of draw that as a little uh loudspeaker
and also i'm holding a loud speaker and
it's shouting out now what's happening
is all these other
systems in the game
you can think of them as ears they're
essentially listening so that's that's
what an ear looks like i guess
uh so you know all these systems are
listening
and what they're listening for is
events in this case the event was hey
i pressed the uh shoot a rocket card
uh so each one of these
systems is actually going to receive
that message but
only the relevant one should respond i'd
like to take some time to
look at the actual code that you know
fuels all this so here we are in the
cards definition file uh this has all
the cards in the game has their color
their name how much it cost
to use them or buy them a little code to
render them as a little glyph that shows
up on the card and game and finally
there is the actual code for handling
what happens when you use the card
none of the actual implementation of
what to do when you use the card lives
in here it actually just outsources all
of that using that exact same strategy
of just emitting what should happen and
all the relevant systems on the other
end are kind of receiving what what what
to do
with
with these uh emits
so
here we are looking at the kepler
missile the same thing we've been
talking about throughout all the
examples
and all it does is says hey
when you use this card
just emit projectile type one it just
says that out into the world and you
know the world of the game needs to then
understand what to do with that so let's
go ahead and look at who might receive
that so here we are i'm looking at the
main game engine that's actually
listening for projectile events and it's
listening for the projectile type as the
only data parameter that comes into it
so just like the projectile creation
code we just looked at here i am in the
audio
manager and we can see right here that
i'm listening to that exact same event
and i receive the actual type if the
type is type one i play the sound for a
missile so here you can actually see all
the sounds for the game i'm just
listening for all sorts of other events
that are going on and i play the
correspondingly correct sound i didn't
have to introduce anything intrusive at
other parts of the game it is all nicely
localized right
here
so why am i bringing this up at all well
mostly because i love using event
emitters and i think they're a very
necessary part of making certain types
of games and
if we look at you know state of the art
libraries like event emitter 3 let's say
for javascript or node
this thing is getting 15 million weekly
downloads like oh my goodness uh so this
sounds like the right thing to use right
yeah well there's only one problem with
that if we go ahead and actually look at
the minified code for it it's it's kind
of massive and it's a bit more
feature-rich than we probably need in
fact this is about you know 3kb it could
probably compress a bit more using a few
of our tools but still this is way too
much code for what we actually need
so we're finally getting to the punch
line of what i'm so excited to share
with you and here it is it's the really
really small version of an event emitter
library that compresses really nicely
here it says it's about 346 bytes but
actually once this goes through a
minifier and uglifier this code will go
down to close to about 112 bytes and i
guess when you run it through road
roller it'll probably be even less than
that in the grand scheme
so uh thanks for tuning in and checking
out shuttle deck i hope you enjoyed what
i had to share about it
at number 10 we have lost a snake in
space by sam
reading on behalf of maxine
hello i'm maxime a web developer and
game developer from france and i
developed my 10th js 13k game entry this
year you can find me on twitter here or
on youtube or on my blog this year i
made a puzzle game where you control a
little snake that visits different
worlds and needs to reproduce the
patterns drawn on the floor with his
body to progress and eventually reach
the moon where he will find the final
hardest puzzles of the game
in each world you learn new mechanics
like climbing walls using teleporters
rapping moving in 3d and so on and it
becomes quite challenging when you pass
the first puzzles
you can play it on pc and mobile right
here
in regards to the code my favorite parts
of the code is the graphics
the first is regarding the snake i spent
many days researching a way to represent
a cute snake in 3d and finally found an
elegant solution that requires very
little code i use a big circle for the
head and many smaller circles for the
body aligning all these circles and
making them move together gives a pretty
good illusion of a snake body with a
real volume even if it's just a bunch of
flat circles rendered with html and css
the game is rendered with a little css
3d library that i developed before the
competition
it is called css 3d framework and you
can find it here it allows us to easily
draw and animate 3d shapes with very
little code
here is the js code for the snake
and here is the css code for the snake
as well
next up i want to talk about the code i
use for the ground textures during the
competition i met pence he creates
gorgeous textures using svgs each of
them is about half a kilobyte which is
perfect for js 13 games where the entire
game size is very limited all the
textures present in my game were created
by him the grass the sand the moon and
even the lava all his csv art can be
found just right here
here are the textures i used in my game
and their minified svg
code
here we have the grass here we have the
sand here we have the moon and here we
have the lava these techniques and many
others are detailed in the game's making
of right over here thanks and see you
next year
at number nine we have black hole square
by quinton klaus
hello
um my name is quinton clausa it's the
first time i submitted something for
js 13k
i've been following the competition
for as long as i can remember
but
yeah this is the first year i submitted
something the game is called black hole
square as you can see
it's
a little bit heavy focus on mobile
controls actually you just tap
the tiles
they move so you have different kinds of
tiles that move in different directions
and goal of the game is to
put all the tiles into black holes
little black holes so you need to clear
the screen
of all the white tiles and
then you finish a level
so
when i'm not participating in the game
jam i keep a text document in which i
write game ideas i have things that come
to mind i write them all down in this
text document and then when a game jam
starts i'll quickly go over it and see
if there are any ideas i can use
actually um this year's idea was
from a sketch i already scribbled down
in my notebooks
so when the gem starts
i create a new document
which will be like a design document for
the game
in which i put to do's
like little notes
i don't actually do all these things
but just if i have any ideas
i just put them in there
and also put the copy in there
so uh the copy for the game
like little sketches for levels
the graphics are
made with
um affinity designer and then i export
them as svg
and then i use tool
called svgo
you can install it with npm globally and
then you can compress the svgs
and then i i am i take out the parts
and i
and i use part 2d to
render
the different parts of the svg
one of the most important
files
in the
code base
is the entity's been json
it contains all the data
from the game
like the order in which the puzzles
are for the game
and the puzzles themselves
so they are just
little arrays
at this point
i always have a very small
notebook in my pocket
so i can make
little
levels
when i'm on the go when i'm waiting for
something i just make little levels
let's make them on paper first
and then uh
afterwards i put them in here one of the
most important files
where most of the code is is the
puzzle.yes
it also contains the keys so there's a
comment which contains the keys which
all the
digits are in the arrays of the levels
as you can see it contains a lot of lot
code like
mostly when i'm working
there's always one file in the code base
that starts uh piling up code in this
project it's the puzzle that yes it's
really a mess like no comments or
it
anything
contains my favorite part of the code
which is an event listener for the wheel
event which actually makes the swiping
like the swiping controls makes them
work on a laptop
if you swipe on the trackpad like it
works on
all the laptops i tried so yeah
listening for the real event you can
make the swiping work on desktop 2 or on
laptops at least
that's it if you want to find out more
about my work you can find me on the
internet on these urls if you have any
questions i'd be happy to answer them
yeah thank you for listening and uh i
hope to see you on another edition of uh
js 13k thank you
in spot 8 we have space huggers by frank
force
howdy
i'm frank force also known as killed by
a pixel
a game developer and generative artist
in austin texas
today i'm going to share with you some
of the secrets behind my js 13k game
space huggers
it's a run and gun rogue-like hybrid
with procedurally generated fully
destructible levels
it has an explosion and fire propagation
system that creates all sorts of
unpredictable chaos and chain reactions
while you're playing
that's what i'm going to show you today
but first let's take a look at the game
and see how it works
you can get the full source code from my
game space huggers off the github
website
i've already gone ahead and downloaded
space huggers and open it up in visual
studio
the first thing i'm going to do is in
app effects i'm going to enable
debug fire
that's going to show us some debug
information when a fire event occurs
for an explosion it's going to show you
two circles and in a radius and outer
radius
the air radius uh represents what ex
what is completely destroyed and the
outer radius is what's caught on fire
when something is on fire
it will
draw a red circle which represent that
a fire event is being sent out to nearby
objects to let them know that they might
also want to catch on fire
these fire events are not set out every
frame but only periodically for
optimization
let's open up app objects and i'll show
you how some of the fire stuff works
you've got a couple variables burn delay
that's how long it is before something
starts burning and a burn time that's
how long something burns for
now in the update function it checks if
it has a burn time that means it can
catch on fire
then it checks is the burn timer set
that means it's burning
so if the burn timer is elapsed that
means it's um you know a lot it's
completely burnt out which means it
tries to tries to die
if there's a fire emitter you have to
turn that off
there's also a small chance to spread
the fire and this is what causes the
really cool chain reactions to happen
you don't want this to happen every
frame because
it's a kind of a slow
system to go through each every each and
every object and
check its radius to see if it's close
enough to catch on fire
of course you can you can do things to
speed that up but it's always going to
be a bit slow so you don't want to do
that kind of thing every single frame
and you don't need to
it's good to have a little bit of
randomness in something like this
it also checks the burn delay timer if
the burn delay timer is elapsed
then it starts burning
um there's um other stuff in here called
um a burn color percent which just kind
of alerts the burn timer to make things
darker as they get burnt
and if you want to burn something
directly you would just call this burn
function
and that
sets up the different stuff to
create the burn system it creates a fire
emitter
and attaches that as a child
it sets the burn timer
and there's also
a way to extinguish fires for example by
just rolling you'll put out a fire or
you can also be near a
water barrel when you explode a water
barrel instead of burning it actually
puts out everything nearby
and it just extinguishes things in a
radius and that sets distinguished timer
it
unsets the fire
effect then timers and sets things back
to normal basically
i hope that gives you a good idea about
how the fire system in my game works and
how you might implement something
similar in your own game
i'm going to give you a quick
demonstration to end things out here
i'd like to tell you to follow me on
twitter
i also
made the game engine
for this game open source
you can get that on my github it's
called littlejs
next year i'll be using littlejs to make
a new game
for uh js15k and i hope that you do too
so uh thanks for watching take care of
yourselves and have a great day
[Music]
in seventh space we have the maze of
space goblins by yani nikanen the maze
of space goblins is a puzzle game that
combines soccer band-like gameplay
mechanics with match 3. the graphics are
extremely retro and work very well for
the type of game that it is the level of
care around the intro and the option to
have the sound on or off was very much
appreciated by the judges you can play
the game by collecting stars to progress
to the next level and by matching three
or more space goblins of the same colour
to destroy them as to make space for you
to move
the game is made to use the arrow keys
to move backspace to undo a move auto
restart and enter to pause the game yani
tested this game on firefox and various
chromium based browsers such as opera
and edge he also tested it on linux and
windows as to make sure the user had the
best possible experience no matter what
browser they were using
the bitmap font was one of my favorite
fonts that i've seen in this competition
this game had also an interesting
approach to creating the levels as you
can see here with the data tag and was
one of the few projects which used
typescript to create that game as you
can see by the tsx files
judge jupiter hadley said he loved the
graphics they were really simple but a
fun game he loved the challenges in it
ralph merton said the name definitely
got my attention funny intro too the
game does a good job of getting you
engaged and he thinks that the puzzles
were excellent and quite challenging
they had been playing for a while
great simple puzzle game that's
deceptively hard with retro visuals and
sound
in sixth place we have packer bunches by
matia futunati
hi i'm matia game developer sometimes
for a b sometimes for work but always
for passion because i really really love
games and game design
i'm very fond of gs 13k games because of
all the creativity you can push with all
the great ideas coming out every year
and so i always try to participate
whenever i can
so now let's jump to my 2021 entry
packages
pack-a-bunches is a colorful tiling
puzzle game in which you have to rescue
space creatures by packing them it is
playable from both desktop and mobile
and as for controls you just use clicks
or taps
i am really proud of this game and not
only because i think it came out to be
very nice but also mainly because i had
a great time making it
in fact my personal goal and approach
this year was to fully enjoy the
creative experience behind the
development of every single part of the
game
let me explain
for example to create the music i didn't
just sit there trying to compose
something
instead i met with a musician friend of
mine and we spent the whole afternoon
listening to puzzle game music from all
nintendo games for inspiration
we had snacks and drinks sharing ideas
in front of the piano and in the end we
came up with this bossa novice jets-ish
course progression for paka bunches
so you see like this whatever the result
i had a great time exploring new things
with a friend
same thing goes for the logo and the
mascot created during some brainstorms
with my girlfriend in which we had fun
exaggerating shapes and trying different
goofy designs with paint for the logo
and pen and paper for the little
character
as for the gameplay since the theme this
year was space i get lost for days
exploring beam packing problems and
space management algorithms
to get some inspiration i eagerly
explored from feng shui principles to
scientific papers on automated furniture
placement
and so i learned many things like
furniture usability rankings
relationships between objects human
navigation in space and so on
in the end as you can see i stuck with a
more simple poly amino shapes packing
game and with some realistic brute force
for level generation but it has really
been an adventure believe me
so maybe now you're curious about pack a
bunch of code about how it can fit in 13
kilobytes and you want to check it on
github
well just don't do it
pack a bunch's code is bad messy full of
mistakes and unused redundant work
around these copy pasty things
no really i couldn't make the code
presentable for the deadline so instead
you should check
this one
this is a basic js 15k games template
which i made post competition which is
somewhat a reorganized cleaner version
of what i use for paco bunches
it includes some features that i
personally see at the moment as
standards in this field of making games
into thin kilobyte and that i like to
reuse myself in the future
many of these solutions are not my own
and every specific owner is created with
links
for example here's the document setup
we have the mid attack to be sure emojis
are shown
and we have a cool chip trick here to
set an emojis fav icon
which will also be the game icon on
mobile if you use the add home page
feature
then we have canvas centering and
resizing handle with leave wrapping
very readable and very solid
as for the audio part my tools of choice
here are the zfx and the zfxm by
frankforts and kit clark
which you may already know and which i
highly suggest you to go and check out
and so like this we have a clickable
centered fit canvas with emojis audio
icon and mobile compatibility i'd say
it's a great starting point to create a
game
but the thing that made it really
possible to fit packer benches into 13
kilobytes and that practically removed
the size constraint is the build process
this year a new javascript compression
tool came out making everyone's life
easier i'm talking about road roller by
keng xiong goon go check it out
so the suggested build process here is
first use google closure compiler to
recompile the code
then tester to crash it and finally
what's roller to compress it
this will extremely reduce the size of
your scripts
so you can now put them inside your
already minified html and zip them at
maximum compression
and here we have one last three couples
leaves using ect we can even optimize
this final zip more reducing its size by
semester bytes
my template also features a batch build
to automate all of this which i
deliberately took from frankfort century
space huggers and modified for my needs
you can find it included in the build
folder or commented along with a link to
the original one thank you frank
so as you can see even when talking
about code i've had a great time keeping
up to date with the gs 13k games world
discovering and playing with all these
great tools
i really really enjoyed making packet
punches
alright thanks for listening thanks to
the freecodecamp staff for the
opportunity of being here thanks to
anjay for keeping the competition up
every year and thanks to the ozone
community for sharing old ideas tips and
projects
thank you guys see ya
in fifth place we have welcome to space
by matthew diamond in this game we play
a hero looking to save their space
station from evil but kind of cute
looking aliens
these wicked aliens are armed to the
teeth but so are you
in this game you can use your vast
arsenal to conquer the six different
alien types and make your way to the
ultimate alien boss
the pixel art was adorable for this game
and the variety given to the weapons and
evil alien characteristics was very
impressive i was most intrigued about
the deciding jump factors that were
there for the aliens so i had a quick
look at the code and must applaud how
neat i found it
here the different types of enemy types
in the game we have the aggro enemy the
run and gun the idiot the pacifists and
the sentinel each with their own colour
scheme for the skin horns eyes and body
you will also see the different ways the
enemies act thanks to their enemy
personas
move your alien in this game you can use
the keyboard or you can use controller
support such as a controller t-pad or
joysticks
on the keyboard you move with either
left and right a and d and jump with
either up or the w key shift or control
as well as shoot with the space bar
make sure to give it a go in the
description below
in fourth place we have galaxy rider by
jab burns
reading on behalf of jeremy burns
hi i'm jeremy burns or jabberins and you
can find me online at jabrons.net
i built galaxy rider for the js 13k
games jam in 2021 this is a game where
the goals and mechanisms are simple and
the difficulty comes from learning to
master the mechanics themselves i've
always liked games where progression
comes from a real improvement of the
player's skill and this game sticks to
the philosophy quite strongly the goal
is simply to collect all the floating
dots and then get the skater to the exit
as fast as possible the initial
challenge is just to complete the levels
at all and replayability comes from the
timer i was inspired to make this game
because i think the physical mechanics
of riding a pool or a bowl on a
skateboard are quite interesting and fun
and i wanted to capture some of that in
a 2d platformer i thought about doing
something like this in 3d but i just
couldn't imagine pulling off a novel 3d
movement mechanic in 3d in the confines
of the jam
my favorite part of the code is probably
the animation editor it's quite ugly
code but it does exactly what was
required of it and nothing more which is
nice in its own kind of way
the way the animation editor works is by
simply rendering some json specified
lines and circles to a large canvas and
giving me a text field in which i can
input that json
it also provides a timeline which i
could scrub to see how animation frames
could blend together and some basic
mouse handles for position editing i
built their character sprite and all the
animations using this tool
the level editor was another minimalist
tool i built for the game though it was
a bit more sophisticated it allowed me
to place positive and negative shapes
into the world which when combined
together formed all the various geometry
you find in the game
overall i think the game came together
quite well and i'm happy that other
people seem to enjoy it too
in third place we have adventures of
captain callisto by cody everson hello
my name is cody eberson i am a software
engineer in san francisco california and
today i'd like to talk about my js 13k
entry the adventures of captain callisto
callisto is a 3d action platform game
set in outer space this is my third time
entering the js 13k competition my first
entry was js 13k battlegrounds in 2018 a
battle royale first person shooter my
second entry was mini punk in 2020 a
cyberpunk third person action game in
those entries my goal was to make an
impressive technical demo the entries
did well graphically but they weren't
considered fun i also noticed that a
significant portion of the js 13k
audience does not really enjoy first
person or third person games so my goals
for this year were to make something fun
make something relatively easy at least
for the first few levels and to make
something with a more global appeal the
most direct inspiration for callisto is
probably captain toad treasure tracker a
nintendo action platform game from a
technology perspective the game
rendering uses webgl 2. i extended my
previous entries to support instance
rendering of cubes and spheres that
means that it's pretty fast and cheap
and low code to draw a sphere or a cube
on the screen all the models are simple
combinations of spheres and cubes as an
example let's talk about the main hero
character we can strip everything away
and then add the components a visor
the rest of the helmet
the
body the jet pack an arm another arm a
leg and another leg and that's how the
rendering works we can then rotate those
spheres to create the animation effects
you see these spheres all over the place
the dust clouds and the coins they're
just stretched spheres here's how that
looks in the code you can see how we
generate the sphere then translate it or
move it then scale it or stretch it and
then in some cases rotate it to create
those animation effects
and that is the foundation of how all of
the rendering works in the entire game
okay that was a quick tour of my entry
the adventures of captain callisto thank
you so much for watching and thank you
to the free code camp team for putting
this together
in second place we have beat rocks by
coz
this game allows you to unleash your
inner dancer the aim is to unlock new
instruments of destruction and make sure
to play them on the beat reading on
behalf of cos cos said
i think this is my third or fourth
attempt at making an asteroid game one
attempt failed because i tried too hard
at making an entity component system
another because i didn't come up with
any asset pipeline so i promise that
i'll try the next one in 3d with
wireframe rendering so that i can have
some nice animations for rotating
objects while keeping the retro it's all
lines visuals
the idea was in my mind for a long time
but i wasn't eager to start until
fatfish told me that js13 is starting
and space is the theme i couldn't pass
over it i wasn't originally planning to
make this a rhythm game the idea
randomly came up later and it seemed to
work i was playing a lot of tetris
effect earlier this year so i tried
toying with the idea of sound effects
contributing to the music
play tests reveal that it is confusing
that when the player uses an ability the
effect triggers immediately but the
sound only plays on the next beat
this led to the conclusion why not
require the player to use skills on the
beat i composed the music on a nintendo
switch then moved it over to soundbox
i'm interested in synths but i have
almost zero experience with composing
it's my longest song so far
some tech facts for you about this game
is that he also used sandbox for sound
effects the sounds were done as other
instruments in the same track so that he
could test how everything sounds
together
since soundbox saves the song as jason
he was able to extract and trim the
soundtracks in the game code to separate
audio buffers
and in regards to the graphics he used
regl
regl gives a convenient typed interface
of a raw webgl that deals away with all
the boilerplate later he's rewritten the
rendering in raw webgl to save space
this was planned for the beginning as he
knew regr would be too big
he then modeled some 3d objects in
sketchup saved to obg and converted a
simple json representation
he also used snippets from patricio
gonzalez vivo's gist for the shader
noise texture which made the background
a little more interesting
in regards to the build and compression
parcel was used for the build pipeline
he likes parcel because it has zero
modules type script and minification by
a tesla with zero setup he'd never used
parcel in production but he used it for
all the toy projects and prototypes
tesla doesn't touch shaders so he
minified them manually using gl slx
and finally let's reveal the number one
winner of the js 13k games 2021
in the number one space we have space
garden by ryan mal
ryan says i've always been inspired by
the fantasy console community and all
the fantastic things they create under
tight constraints
space garden is the third game i've made
for js 13k
space garden is the third game i've made
for just
space garden is the third game i've made
for js13k that uses similar constraints
via a simple drawing api and frame
buffer i've refined over the years
that's heavily inspired by fantasy
consoles in my free time i've been
working on cleaning up retrobuffer for a
more official release so other jammers
might more easily make a game with it
i'd love to see that a huge thank you to
andrei and everyone else involved with
managing js 13k is the highlight of my
year to participate
and there we have it all 20 winners from
the js that